that d'un pape dans la chaleur et la
poussière
image le premier convoi des cent mille
réfugiés cure
la frontière est en haut de cette
montagne à quelques centaines de mètres
depuis mardi dernier
elle est complètement fermée à l'armée
irakienne derrière cette montagne
quarante mille kurdes sont aujourd'hui
le cirque à eux nous réussit à passer au
bord d'une rivière s'improvise un
campement le silence se plaît parfois le
bruit lointain de kannad et par
bourrasques 7,6 reconnaissable de deux
morts leur maison était la barre à bien
ginai barral ou alan tous ces villages
du kurdistan bombardé de manière
terrifiante depuis le 27 juillet
les enfants sont contents quand la
marque précieux et sur la proue de la
bizarre gouvernement turc d'abord
surpris par la soudaineté et
l'importance
j avec nous grande efficacité tous les
camions de la région ont été
réquisitionnés jour après jour se
forment d'interminables convoi ont
transporté en étant mieux aménager ces
milliers de réfléchir et derniers
kilomètres ne sont pas les plus faciles
sous un soleil de plomb et sur les
prismes terre et de cailloux
il faut encore attendre que la route
solitaire dans les gorges étroites de la
vallée du m'zab le moindre incident on
obtient des dizaines et des dizaines de
camions
ils sont dix mille aujourd'hui dans ce
convoi de réfugiés bloqués ici un camion
est en panne et bloquent la route depuis
plusieurs heures
dix mille réfugiés ils ont quitté leurs
villages le 25 août à la suite de leurs
terribles bombardements chimiques
il marchait la nuit se cachant le jour
et on franchit les cols à plus de 3000
mètres sur ces montagnes est très
difficile d'accès parmi tous ces
réfugiés on trouve aujourd'hui de
nombreux témoignages sur la gravité des
bombardements ils viennent d'avoir lieu
au kurdistan
huit avions sont arrivés un matin ils
ont lâché des bombes à excuser les rouge
et jaune
et après tout le monde était mort les
vaches aussi tous les animaux c'est
terrible témoignages se multiplient dès
l'arrivée au point de yuksekova à 40
kilomètres de la frontière irakienne
avant même d'installer les tentes mises
à leur disposition ils viennent à nous
et avec une grande dignité nous disent
l'horreur vient de subir un vote qui a
l'oreille du phosphore qui brûlait les
chapeaux des gaz lors du napa et pire
que tout les siennes il proposait
d'ouvrir tous les héros des passionnés
et ce père nous montre sa petite fille
qui a perdu ses cheveux
là où sa tête et le seul pendant son
sommeil donc s'ils atteignent tout en
imprégner le succès chimiques nous
présente son bpa ce sont les
signalisations d'armes chimiques sa
direction continuent de nier
pas de blessés graves ici seuls les
blessés légers que franchir la montagne
mais tous ces réfugiés qui arrivent de
jour comme de nuit ne sont pas encore
sortis de toutes leurs épreuves
ce camp est à 2000 mètres d'altitude
dans deux mois il fera
moins 20 degrés la nuit il y aura deux
mètres de neige et dans tous ces temps
qui s'est exactement 10 20 et 30 mille
enfants de moins de 10 ans